[Applaudissements]
cyril hanouna
mais non
je suis
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le front syndical est vraiment renforcé
par ça fait longtemps qu'on n'avait pas
assisté à une telle mobilisation
unitaire de grève la grèce dont la grèce
la ligne rouge a été franchie on va
revoir ses boucles et les images et
faisons entrer les chroniqueurs qui sont
prêts oui oui fongrave allez dites leur
qu'ils viennent et on est pressé merci
regarder le bras de fer se poursuit
entre grévistes et non grévistes
laissons les autres chroniqueurs amaury
nous donne la responsabilité de donner
les informations aux salariés et après
les salariés savent très bien se
positionner sur le fait de savoir s'il
accepte ou si le refuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là c'est moi qui parle pendant des
particuliers tout n'était pas là j'ai
été élu à l'unanimité des délégués du
personnel et des chroniqueurs
ça veut dire qu'à partir de maintenant
gênant mais ya pas de mon bébé là c'est
fini les accords tu seras toujours mon
bébé qu'une angoisse moi bah ouais bah
ça veut bien
[Applaudissements]
tu as vu le match hier j'ai vu m'a dit
moi bordeaux marseille marseille
bordeaux
je n'ai pas vu les marseillais précédé
bordelais 1
j'ai fondu si je n'ai pas vu prendre le
premier plus en contre ils ont rien vu
arriver
un deux contre cinq il y avait cinq
marseille et de bordeaux demande si j'ai
vu le match en moins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi je